hey this is mark Walton for GameSpot at
Gamescom 2014 i'm here with cameron
robinson and we have just seen a
blood-borne yeah
combat tell me about this combat okay so
that's basically what they were showing
mainly was they were like hey we want to
show you what's new in the gameplay
what's different from the games I made
before like Dark Souls and Diesel's so
the big thing take away I had any way is
it looks quite a bit faster and although
they were keen to stress that are still
gonna be really difficult you should I
alot it does look like they've toned
down some of the punishing aspects of
those games of Dark Souls and demons
souls and the coolest thing I thought
that was the weapons sleep now got these
transformer weapons which is quite cool
so you've got like a screamer thing
which you can then hit a button and it
goes much longer as your attacks are
more powerful and you can use that's
like not bad or you've got these this
like one handed axe which then
transforms into two-handed axe and it
just that enables you to mix up your a
strategic combat and it is all still a
bit strategy there wasn't it yeah I mean
absolutely the idea behind these weapons
was that you're able to use them in
really different ways and figure out the
way you want to play as it were but yeah
I mean it's very cool and it all ties in
to basically what is the new mechanic
for this game is the wii game system and
the idea behind this is that you have
when you attack an enemy there's a
little yellow bar that appears on the
screen and if you get hit at any point
by their enemy you have taught by the
time before that yellow bar disappears
you have to hit them and then you get
the hell's back basically encourages you
to react with combat rather than backing
away exactly to trying to make it a bit
more notnot frantic but just a bit more
like exchanging hits rather than hidden
runaway hit and run away that type of
idea so we do ticket you have it pays
the deal damage back absolutely and you
don't have to hit the enemy that hit you
you can anyone anyone around you know
they were keen to stress about this that
they don't want this to be regarded as a
frantic hack and slash name and it is
there was a little bit more of that in
there but it certainly it's definitely
not I'm gonna be like off the wall crazy
like the sort of like DMC or you know
sort of games it's still very got much
got that sword Dark Souls vibe to it and
it's really dark and the graphics are
beautiful yeah it's all like blues and
blacks and little bits of orange and it
looks gorgeous and the clothes all kind
of ripple in the wind and its really
atmospheric and it does have them I
think
in a big difference is a lot more horror
like influence in this game yeah which
is cool it like the audio was really
quite scary at times disease well we had
watched this one better gameplay where
they entered into this like graveyard
there's all these old women monsters
like lurking around and they're pretty
terrifying they were terrifying and the
thing about that was their canes point I
was that there's a different strategy
for every enemy there's everyone has a
different weakness so in terms of the
old ladies they were saying because
they're old and a little bit you know a
little bit flaky know nowadays you can
actually roll into the more that does is
destabilize them because their bones a
week that gives you opportunity to
attack that's just one example of that
but there are many more and the other
thing that they did in the game was
change the HUD as well which to make it
more accessible so this this all ties
into is still difficult but a little bit
easier to get to grips with so now
health is a constant you basically hit
triangle and you've always got your
health boost rather than having to
select it as an item and map it to your
items thing and then you've got that
means you free to experiment with some
of the other items more like you had
what was it you could throw oil oil and
then follow up with a Molotov cocktail
which yeah deal extra damage yeah so if
you you know if you've got alarm bells
ringing thinking all this sounds like
they've nerfed dark souls or things like
that I don't think it is that way
because you've got a lot of strategy
options it looks like in the items and
in your changeable weapons and in the
fact that every enemy has like a
specific weakness so they're still looks
to be lots of strategy makamba yeah I
mean the game is looking great and it's
actually playable on the gamescom show
floor so I think we're gonna go check it
out later this week and hopefully we'll
be able to bring you more but for now
keep it gamespot